okay stream is up ready to go yeah
Visioneer [ __ ] flip it all I'm
thinking that she might be are can you
guys not look at porn while I [ __ ] do
this shows the girls five [ __ ]
minutes okay let's roll
okay for five minutes starting ready go
now what's up everybody and welcome back
to the virzi effect podcast show my name
is Paul virzi and today is Monday
October 27th 2017 and you guys are
listening to episode 329 and a [ __ ]
doozy I have for you people today I am
sitting here in the beautiful incredible
amenities filled all things comedy
studios here off of whizzes Washington
Street or you guys don't give a [ __ ]
it's it's a nice day here they have
green room here they have some Tito's
they have some beer we have some snacks
but more importantly I have three guests
guys you guys know I've been doing this
show this December 8 years and out of
the 8 years out of the 329 episodes I
might have had what maybe 40 guests well
today the virzi effect is loaded I have
three amazing guests with me so funny
from all walks of life I have the very
funny court McCown hey buddy
hailing from Oklahoma by California by
way of Oklahoma yeah I have Ryan Sickler
hilarious comic and I have the always
entertaining and wild Billy O Connor
originally from the Bronx
came over on the boat I was on the boat
we're here about we're here at the all
things comedy inaugural all things
comedy festival and I got to tell you I
got in here it was a thrash I got in
here yesterday I got a [ __ ] fly out
tomorrow but what a fun time for comedy
festivals first one and I'm not just
saying this I was talking about on
social media for a comedy festivals
first night first festival ever
usually comedy festivals at the
beginning or a [ __ ] show let's be honest
you get that yeah we're trying to do
this thing it's one block it's in Utah
it sucks nobody [ __ ] cares and it's
all unorganized you're at a shitty thing
you show up this has been I actually
said this and I know it's
statement but from the first night it's
been like the closest thing that I've
had to a jfl experience as far as
getting shuttled here going there
everything has been done right the Tempe
Arizona Ryan was there they shut us over
there came after you heard nothing yet
this guy was a [ __ ] bookie Vietnam
started stand-up at 62 you don't even
[ __ ] know everybody at the inaugural
festival eight weeks out it's not really
but I'm here the the opening night was
unbelievable and and then we went then I
did Ari's podcast which was great and
it's just been such a good time and you
graduate a pizza box a [ __ ] notch in
a pizza box of chicken nachos which was
the late that mistake that I wish you
didn't remind me of but there's gonna be
a great show guys first before I get
started I just want it to a shout out
the sponsors diversity effect podcast is
sponsored by chassis chassis for men
that's right guys it is some of you
people know that's why they're laughing
people say it's the only podcast whose
sponsor I love to hear the sponsor
chassis is a powder for your testicles
it is called man care for down there and
is one of the greatest products on the
market Fred McGriff is also a part of
this [ __ ] oh yeah Kenny main chassis
ferments a fine powder that just the
dryness the no chafing that my balls
have been pristine there's no doubt
there's no parabens there's no menthol
to all-natural powder and my nuts have
never been more pristine I'm not even
kidding you I have doctors pediatricians
going hey man I heard your podcast
thanks so much for that chassis plug
this is my I've never felt better down
there it's incredible you don't like you
don't like a little menthol burn right
after a good shave you know because that
feels fantastic no burn expense I would
use powder and I won't say another
competitors money well I mean your plug
I'm telling you this right switch up my
pal I'm going to tell you right now you
get this bottle I'm gonna give you a
bottle this chassis and that's it I've a
bladder my balls we lived for that no
dude it is latest thing it is it is
insane it's a great project you get a
chassis from men that's eh a ssis
chassis from men calm also on amazon
also city living dog guys go to city
living dog calm and coach mike he's one
of the best dog trainers in the
Northeast and he helped my dog he's
amazing people from the verge effect
I've been going to him getting help you
could see all of his YouTube clips you
could see his Facebook live all of his
Instagram and all that and of course all
things comedy guys that's why we're here
al Madrigal put this thing together with
Bill burr and all of these amazing
podcasts and that's why I got people
that do when you meet Ryan Sickler you
and that guy are gonna like each other
instantly and we did instant it was I
mean it was like I've known the guy
drinking the guy for [ __ ] 20 years
and I met him less than 24 hours ago
doing shows court I've met you years ago
and we did a podcast we did your podcast
in LA this guy's the [ __ ] scratch
golfer he was in [ __ ] Teen Wolf
can't buy me levels the other one
[Laughter]
I don't do sequels that was what I shot
would do a sequel if they had a sequel
then they bring Teen Wolf back as a TV
show with Marnie Adams come on yeah
that's just angry you know just an angry
guy yelling at all his students I was
lodged my standup I got a special coming
out tape and a special next week you
better [ __ ] be there you're all get
apps no I liked when you told me
yesterday at Michael J Fox with a
sweetheart I like sweetheart I like
hearing that [ __ ] yeah me too you know I
like here and he looks like a guy that
if you found out he wasn't it'd be
devastating
like if somebody's a guy Michael J Fox a
[ __ ] you know you'd be like oh
really you know know sweetheart of a guy
nice nice house it can't heat catties or
court but his [ __ ] clubs are all over
to God I don't let him read putts we
bring up the guys twitch that's really
small talk when he meets somebody like a
great things listen how you doing
[Laughter]
your kids notice when you make breakfast
I'm glad he's doing good he's doing all
right seem like he's got another got
another job so it can't be that yeah you
know you can't be that [ __ ] up I mean
that guy did what family ties for like
15 guys got [ __ ] ton of money he back to
the future all those movies yes he's
okay
got that [ __ ] I mean would you rather
money you'll be able you know your
plumbing works your [ __ ] vertical
nuts it hurts listen if I [ __ ] the money
yeah
so Billy let's start with you let's
start with you yeah let's get on it okay
you are you started stand-up you went to
Florida State as a freshman at 53 years
old so Florida State University of
flowers a university flower my
girlfriend was an academic you know what
I mean she was like she was getting a
doctorate degree on ER you know they
they gave her a free doctorate degree I
was jogging by two universes the [ __ ] I
go to school I snotty right and people
started reading then I said you know
what one of these days I'm gonna want to
pitch a book so I said you know I see
these [ __ ] kids to would stand up
they're all like 18 19 years old 20 year
old kids and then we'll talk about
jerking off you know I told me cuz
that's all they talk about cuz I didn't
do anything
that's all you do when you're in college
it's the same [ __ ] you know you could be
the greatest writer in the world you get
out of school 22 you haven't done
anything [ __ ] you gonna write about
anyway say god help the writer or
whenever water go well run then I mean I
grew up the streets in the Bronx I was
the [ __ ] Vietnam after Vietnam I was
a bookie for a while then I was a
bartender with a couple of bars I was
doing drugs booze I [ __ ] more women at
Frank Sinatra I was having a great
[ __ ] time bad decisions make good
stories well I made a million benches
well I'm the only [ __ ] guy I know
with my business is broke and you'll get
on stage for the first time doing
stand-up at 62 years old and seeing
everybody probably what 20s 30s right at
the most and you just you just walk in
like [ __ ] I'm gonna try this or
someone want to do yeah you know what I
always want to give it a shot so it was
three minutes give me three minutes you
know and of course I was [ __ ]
terrified but but then I want to get up
there was interesting because I was a
gamble I was a bookie right in the first
three minutes I was like wow this is the
same rush you get when you bet [ __ ]
5000 on a game with no money right I
like Jews rushing
what odds did you give yourself that you
need a big bowl of [ __ ] it's immediate
gratification we're writing you don't
get that right also would stand up and
you get big audiences you could throw
out ideas and I mean you try eight nine
jokes and to really hit we said that
goes to the book that's that's a book
right you can you know you're writing is
performance right it's like instant yeah
right
so I've been told [ __ ] useless words
and good comedy is about getting to the
[ __ ] punch light as fast as you can
right I mean with this setup is you know
what storytelling that's so interesting
man and and you wrote a book it's a
great book Confessions of a Bronx bookie
that was my first book it's about sex
drugs gambling in the mob everybody to
make this country great yeah I got lucky
up Stevie Van Zant from the E Street
Band started pushing it for me which was
cool yeah yeah the second book I got
high hopes for cuz it's about 9/11 it's
uh it's about the fire department but
the real deal not themself [ __ ] where
like it you don't like I make this book
makes rescue me look like the [ __ ]
Muppet movie I want it back I want to
back up with something cuz sometimes on
the verge effect there is a sports
segment not much I'll just talk about
you know the heartbreak the Yankees lost
what's going on the Giants Knicks always
suck real quick but you you say now I
want to talk about fixed games and I
want to talk about [ __ ] that is that is
really cuz we have somebody here I mean
I know that you knew mob guys and you
were doing all coming out we want to
keep it you know but I know you know
[ __ ] okay and I know you were a part of
[ __ ] during a certain time in your
estimation percentage-wise today in 2017
when you watch a game
can you watch and know or think this
this that point
to being shaved or that that that call
was because of something in order for
either the leek to make money or for
something can you can you can you see
that today yeah here's the deal I don't
look at games like like I used to cuz
you know I had so much [ __ ] money on
them I used to be glued to him now I
just watch the scores but no I tell how
a game is [ __ ] up
this is so great I'm you look at a game
on Monday right suppose like like this
week the wolves
they're kicking ass lately right they've
won 4-2 out here looking like they can't
[ __ ] be stopped then going home they
open up at nine and a half over the
Bears right yeah Monday the line opens
up at nine and a half the line drops to
nine eight and a half and you say to
yourself okay who the [ __ ] is betting
money on the best right this is
impossible I should be going to ten
doesn't have you look for a game that's
counterintuitive a game it's going the
wrong way right right
Tuesday because that's what the wise
guys bet the general public bet on
Sunday Saturday you can't change your
line on Sunday because there's so much
money on a game already a $5,000 bet
ain't gonna do [ __ ] but a $20,000 bet on
a Monday he's gonna move a line now if
it's moving the wrong way you've got to
say to yourself why is that [ __ ] line
moving the wrong way and guess what if
it's between you and the bookies the
bookies are usually right so well the
general public is gonna pile on the
wallets I guarantee the Bears win this
week now if I watch that game and I see
I don't bet him anymore cuz right now
you make my bed so you can lose your
mind right because I've lost so much
[ __ ] money you can't win I mean you
know you can't beat the percentages but
you look at if I look at a game like
that and I see a defensive holding call
from the inferior line on the 10-yard
line you go I'm sorry to the virzi
effect listeners in Vegas who stopped
this and ran to put that Bellagio it's a
riot a riot court and me we're looking
at you like we just saw like an alien
land we were so interested in that [ __ ]
to a layman they first did he think when
I hear bookmaker they say okay you like
Dallas you like the Giants you bet a
thousand on Dallas 2000 ah Giants
witches against each other I take 100
bucks right Tepes it right that ain't
how it works that's [ __ ]
that's complete [ __ ] here's how it
works if you've got 12 games on a Sunday
maybe six games will be really important
feel like you just not [ __ ] anyway so
there'd be six games that'd be really
important to you of course the last game
Sunday night game if you New York Giants
Dallas you know six games to meet a lot
now with the juice with the 10% all you
got to do of those six games is when two
of them and you break even because with
the juice you're right even right if you
win freedom you make money if you win
for them you crush because you're
getting juice if you win five you wipe
them out so anybody there at the right
mind is gonna hold six games on the
premise I only got to be right 206 and I
break even right so you don't gotta
worry about laying off money because it
will you Paulo players are gonna go
broke anyway so why should I take
[ __ ] 5,000 and you're gonna go broke
on eventually yeah by the end of the
year and lay it off with him and give
him your money so Chuck can you just
tell this story about the guy who was
having a really hard time gambling was
considered my buddy please buddy blinky
[ __ ] yeah my buddy blinky he's got a
gambling problem
blinky he had lost like [ __ ] 16 games
in a row right every [ __ ] week two
games toilet it blow it down a [ __ ]
south south south 16 games in a row fine
he says you know what [ __ ] this I'm
calling a service call one ease guys
these five-star services he calls the
guy he gets the [ __ ] credit card guy
system now look put the credit card
engine number on the back yeah yeah and
this is all five-star release he says
you know this is uh we don't release
this all the time to wonder dollars paid
on him it's okay I did it what's the
game what's the game he goes calls this
is the Colts
[Laughter]
oh that's great
Ryan Ryan Sickler is here everybody
originally from Baltimore which that was
a Baltimore cold story right there yeah
man number seven yeah and you were a
Baltimore Colts fan I was until they
left yeah now did you start stand-up in
but did you start stand-up in Bolton I
did very briefly though I started
stand-up in Baltimore when I was 20 but
then life got in the way and I didn't
start again until I was 27 in LA okay
Wow Wow
what kind of life got into a lot of
people's life ending gonna be like my
dad died then I was living with my
grandma man she died so it was all work
work work actually I have a bookie story
because it you I wanted to ask you did
you ever run numbers well numbers is
like what most guys doing bars and they
usually give that to the runners like
Joe Pesci used to be a runner for a big
book what's running numbers explain
running numbers to me well I'll tell you
how this I'll tell you how this guy did
it yes so I worked it to put myself
through college I worked at UPS South
ups Baltimore hub primary one Joe Avenue
oh [ __ ] my stepfather worked at UPS
there you go 25 years yes delivers to my
house my way got to know the everybody
and there was one guy that was sit in
the cafeteria but this is a hub this was
still Teamsters full-time one of the
last full-time hubs and the you know
it's a monster building this guy was on
but he had gotten out of prison and his
job through the state was he was
responsible for filling all the vending
machines and everything it I would say
that cafeteria was big is all the way
this whole entire room he okay
and it's just lined up vending machines
with sandwiches and you know all you
know this combo you slide the window
open there's a meal and [ __ ] in there
like he was in charge all that keeping
everyone's lunches form and [ __ ] that
was the job that the state gave him
after he got out of prison he got out of
prison he went to prison on a life
sentence did 18 got out for good
behavior because he came home and found
his best friend in bed with his wife and
he
got them and I think he killed the best
friend and the wife made it out and back
then they didn't have temporary insanity
or any of these pleas that they came up
with later so he served a 20-year life
sentence got out in 18 this was the job
the state gave him was you working the
[ __ ] UPS cafeteria and stocked the
food and stuff but he couldn't make a
lot of money doing that so his sock
hustle was two things he was a bookie he
would do all our [ __ ] football
college bets everything and then he also
ran numbers and the way he did it was
you used a lottery that's on TV that's
still your numbers that's still
everything but instead of giving the
government your money
you give it to me and then if you hit
you get paid more and you don't get
taxed so it behooves you to pay me to do
this we're still gonna use this system
you see on TV here but your money's not
going over here it's coming over here
right so every night he'd have a pick
three and a pick four and he'd leave
around mmm I'd work doubles he'd
probably leave around 7:00 and he would
just leave a piece of a napkin sitting
on the table and there would just be
three numbers and four numbers and
everybody would have to go through the
cafeteria to get to the restroom so
everybody took their break to walk by
and check and I played a pick four with
him for months and one night I got there
late and you know there's no texting or
anything then he's like where were you I
said man I got stuck in traffic I got
he's your numbers hit your number said I
go calm the [ __ ] on I would just throw a
buck down yeah and that night it hit box
and boxes like if you have one two three
four that means that those numbers can
come up in any order you can play
straight you come yeah it's like Brett
was so hoarse it's like what horses Zach
yeah any number and hit that night and
for that buck I would have made twenty
five hundred [ __ ] dollars I was
devastated
no but you got scared of the guy no he
was this older white dude to do his name
was I probably shouldn't so I guess I
can say yeah if you [ __ ]
if the guy popped into a room and
started shooting people I don't want to
you know yeah I mean if blinky ain't
coming down no he's around pinky studio
powderpuff [ __ ] real-deal holes in
your ass yeah they give the numbers to
the runners because it's like the odds
are like if you picked freenode three
numbers right they pay you six hundred
to one right it's the end of the
paramutual usually the paper what they
waiting to win New York the open the
paramutual the last three numbers of
paramutual that's the number for the day
they pay 600 well of course is a
thousand numbers so the odds are a
thousand to one so you're shaving 40
percent you can't [ __ ] lose so
numbers are that can I tell you Don King
yeah got his start as a kid seven years
old that's how smart this [ __ ]
was he used to buy peanuts and he put a
tip on the number and every bag of
peanuts that he's selling the gambling
parlor and he keep track of all the
numbers and if a guy hit the number II
come back and say how about a tip and
their number you know wow that's how
[ __ ] slick he was Don King back at 7
years old that's what he wanted where
did he grow up Detroit no the jungle
would [ __ ] alley on his way there he
came back was back what was for but he
came back but Ali I don't know [ __ ] so
and court court you are a you are a
[ __ ] professional golfer basically
I'm not a professional golfer you're a
scratch go well here's my decent golfer
to me listen I know you catty
for some of the pros but here's the
thing when you're a scratch golfer to me
can you if you played Augusta if you
played a Guster what would you or would
you shoot it you could shoot a 70 I
don't know man a Gus is a tough track
you know it's tough there's the what's
though I mean there's guys there that
shoot five pros that shoot five over you
know who knows I mean that you break 80
they're probably break 80 there you
could break any there I would say I
would say I would put put good odds I
like a break but also but also that that
thing is shaved like those fairways are
shaved and there's no like a gust is the
one golf course why Tiger Woods had so
much
that's there is that you can you can
miss there's only a couple holes that
you really can't miss your drive the
rest of the time and there's no there's
like there's there's no real rough there
so there's so like Tiger Woods jordan
Spieth like jordan Spieth his miss is
high right if you ever watched jordan
Spieth play golf he's ready when his
drive misses to the right that's his
miss so Augusta is one of these golf
courses where if you miss high if you
miss to the right you're in that you're
in the pine straw you're not you're not
buried you're not you're not in you're
not you're not blocked out so these
mistakes at Augusta doesn't don't really
kill him don't really come Tiger was the
same way Tigers missed was a big push
right and so Tiger could bomb it at the
time before they they call it Tiger
Tiger done done is tight it will go just
no reckless driving charge like
yesterday or so no no no that's a while
ago that's what it like that's like that
fall from grace I put up there with like
that's one of the biggest faults when
you're talking about a guy that you know
was not only was he on beat I mean I
said that like the trail like how
unbeatable was that guy
he was completely unbeatable he was also
an [ __ ] I mean like tight like I used
to catch everybody great is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jordan's a [ __ ] it everybody
was great like that we can't play Tiger
man come on [ __ ] kill King Kong man we
got no chance against [ __ ] Plains
didn't kill that beast club once you
make that [ __ ] monkey crazy [ __ ]
killed King Kong is the line kill what
else I don't care what the [ __ ] else is
said on this podcast in the next however
long I'm on here [ __ ] killed Kong King
is the line I used to caddy for yes per
Parnevik so yes we're part of expend my
friend for 15 years
his his nanny married Tiger Woods so I
met I met Tiger when they first started
dating so I met them in 2000 I met him
in 2001 Wow when him and aliens just
first started dating then they it was
very private they kept it private no one
really knew they dated they dated for a
long time before they
it came out then they got married he was
never like the friendliest guy but I
would go have dinner I would have dinner
with with yes Bruins wife Mia and Elia
and Tiger we would you know we'd have
dinner together I met him several
several times always a dick just not
friendly just not a friendly guy and
then one night we were one night I was
in Florida visiting yes but I was doing
Palm Beach improv Joel bash golf club
and I was doing Palm Beach improv and I
went there to see yes / and yes / just
had hip replacement surgery so he's
literally in bed with the Machine moving
his leg recuperating from this surgery
and the next night I went down to Miami
to go to the Colts Dolphins Monday night
game well the owners of Buddy mind so
we're up in the box and he goes Oh
Peyton gave Tiger a field pass and he
goes Tigers probably gonna come up in
the box he goes just you know let's all
be cool and you know whatever I go I
could give a flame I met this guy like
10 [ __ ] times he gives a [ __ ]
and so we're were he walks in the box
now this is this is like September
before the November meltdown so this is
like a month and a half before this all
this shows you are welcome virzi effect
listeners you got bookmaking you got all
this [ __ ] snow so I go so Tiger comes
up in the Box he says hello to everybody
in the box and then and then he sees me
and he just kind of looks at me and he
just kind of gives me one of these like
those [ __ ] head nods like the quick
yeah like the quick head nod like [ __ ]
you and then goes back to texting on his
phone and I was like what a [ __ ] dick
yeah so I call up Mia I call up yes pers
wife in it the next day and I was in
Miami and I go you wouldn't believe this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I go I met I tell her the story and she
goes hang on and she grabs she's I'm on
her cellphone she grabs her home phone
she calls up tiger and she goes you
[ __ ]
and she's dead she just goes do you know
how many times in our lives we have like
been nice to people that come up and say
they're your friend and you and we're
[ __ ] we're nice to them and we're you
know you know we Sui don't we treat them
like [ __ ] and
then you have somebody who you [ __ ]
know you [ __ ] you son-of-a-bitch
she goes I can't [ __ ] believe you
would do that to court she goes you're
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and she just
[ __ ] hangs up the phone Michael J Fox
never treated a bike down yeah and so
and so she hangs up oh yeah and then she
gets back home she goes I took care of
that and I was like she let you hear our
lady she's a European chick - he's
Swedish power later she calls me she
goes Tiger wants to leave you a message
can I give him your phone or I go [ __ ]
no don't get my phone number
really yeah so she was like he was like
real apologetic so then cut to a month
later and what you know what he was
doing was is he was texting [ __ ] on his
phone right he was down to Miami [ __ ]
and he was down there doing one of his
little [ __ ] break
recon message not his own bumble then he
just take him up in the plane yeah that
guy had the greatest deck I mean I gotta
say though if you're gonna bang girls
and you got billions of dollars the way
you do it is you get them you tell your
wife you got a business meeting you go
get on your jet you fly around [ __ ]
midair and then land get him off the
plane and go yeah it was a great
business meeting okay the guy that did
it right is Derek Jeter oh god just
don't get married yeah he was the
[ __ ] Captain Tigers downfall was
Tigers downfall was that he came from
this military father who was so on top
of him his whole life I mean that guy
was like a thumbs down on him his entire
life and then his dad passes away he's
married with kids and he's like [ __ ] it
I got nobody to answer to now this is
the first time in his life he's been
free so he's banging Hooters waitresses
I mean he didn't even bang hot chicks do
you see some of these I use it but
here's my question about here's my
question about this though how does that
[ __ ] your game up like if you have a
jump shot you have a jump shot no cuz
Golf is 90% mental
90% of its mental you look at all the
guys that are out there playing and you
see how on tour how one week some guy is
just better than everybody else that
week it's just he is he [ __ ] got
dialed in his putter got hot you think
its confidence just it's all confidence
by Tiger one so much because back then
man Tiger had the lead and you're like
well there's gone there's no holding
catching this guy and it's like heat
there's no way I can catch this guy
nowadays they no confidence if you don't
imagine being going anywhere in the
world where people are just [ __ ] on
you all the time like even if you had a
scandal it would not be on the level of
a Tiger Woods scandal where they're
talking about it in [ __ ] China and
[ __ ] that's the thing like it's
everywhere like we get upset if like one
of our friends is like hey dude they're
talking about you down the comedy club
so you're like me who the [ __ ] could you
imagine muscle you're the cover of
Moscow if they had a picture you
standing over that nacho box last night
on the cover of the newspaper you would
be upset about that man pretending like
you just yeah what made a great point
about that about the father being don't
you get loose man I was 18 years only
sent me to Vietnam I got the Vietnam
prostitute for $4 a piece I was a
remembered as a recovering Catholic
[ __ ] I've ever heard I was a recovering
Catholic my testosterone was through the
roof I could handle three 2412 you walk
into a [ __ ] bar there'd be a hundred
[ __ ] names on a big electronic board
and a hundred girls dancing with numbers
on that back you just go number two
number 16 number 21 and then two minutes
later around here you pay mama I always
get I'd always take I always take number
69 just I can take 16 oh yeah and then I
was getting I bet I would have [ __ ]
the rock if I thought it was a snake
[Laughter]
but how is that what does that have to
do with the war switch your way [ __ ]
got the right to say okay alright so if
so were you worried about STDs [ __ ] like
what the collapse so many [ __ ] times
I had my own coffee mug over you you can
still get it I remember I remember
college we didn't we didn't have any of
that [ __ ] man in college we didn't have
any [ __ ] yeah it was like there was no
STDs now it's the only catch in a clap
and all kinds of [ __ ] we never use the
problem we don't for the rain going on
with the [ __ ] you know I probably was
with I'd say roughly 600 broads right in
a year right
am I supposed to I'm 23 years old but
well for a burger in a movie Billy that
ship is gone I'm gonna I'm gonna give
you $4 and you're gonna [ __ ] my brains
out that $4 you were you getting a
prostitute every day Billy you know
three days just do urges all day that's
what soldiers were doing was just
[ __ ] that's what I always do it on
with the rest of the would going I
didn't give a [ __ ] you know they were
losing is like the war program is right
really he was supposed to be ma during
this [ __ ] I was playing poker I was
making money the guy that's supposed to
be doing the strategies bangin Vietnam
was like a resort
Billy's got poker Billy's got poker at
three and he's got three hookers she's
locked up today after payday three days
straight I play poker take the suckers
all that buddy right that I'd [ __ ]
the downtown I'd be buying our a toss
from guys you married you don't want to
get the clap is five hundred I think
you're wrong are right good downtown
wait what's wrong what's the are
non-western recreation relaxing oh you
mean you bought their time oh my I
didn't get quaaludes right over the
drugstore rope at us today see no
problem right over the club weed I was
paying us a bottle but you held your
hands up like a threeway Laotian we I
get a shopping bag full away you should
we for twenty bucks a shopping bag full
week I'd be [ __ ] chopping it up
thrown a drink to rest off the table the
president they were like yeah this one
guy the presidents like get me in
general why is the same [ __ ] area
losing
[Laughter]
yeah it was [ __ ] Philly if it's
[ __ ] your fault Vietnam I tell you
what man when I came back I started
bookmaking I stopped I went through the
wallets right he came back with no but
the legitimately legitimately oh my guys
are coming back with PTSD just got the
STD six hours of [ __ ] took the u.s.
down
[Applause]
well least we waiting a good cause
legitimately the two [ __ ] most
poignant things I ever heard about
Vietnam and I read everything I get my
hands out about Nam when I came back was
Tim O'Brien with the things they carried
two quotes what he said and this is true
all the [ __ ] time I had it was great
but still you're 23 years old it's an
amazing [ __ ] alteration of your life
he said when I came back from Vietnam I
had the strangest feeling that I was
older than my father and that's
absolutely true you get that and the
other thing he said was do you have any
idea what it's like for a 20 year old
kid to be walking through a napalmed
village and see pigs eating roast people
I just think about that what that's a 20
year old kid seeing that [ __ ] but you
never saw them know number 2 number 7
number 14 to eat that [ __ ]
rip those dialogues spit out lipstick
your day was so different than the guys
in the [ __ ] oh my god your buddy bill
bear does a great bit about that I saw
him do that that bit when you open for
him at the Tempe improv any think the
bit about let that be a prophet he says
you know not all of these guys were
heroes okay you refused all yeah he does
a bit about the aircraft yeah guys tell
me thanks for your service I'm like [ __ ]
it thank you for said to me but it's
like I had a ball yeah he had one
uniform he only had one uniform and like
50 pair under your picture Billy at the
University of Florida in history class
and they're talking about the
devastation of Vietnam and he's looking
around like it wasn't really that bad I
got a can we talk about the wars history
teacher UF is just to be in front of the
whole class right he's talking he says
and you know in the sixties these guys
at social consciousness they know he
went out in the streets and it protested
the war and they'll march of a civil
rights and I'm like and he goes yeah
Billy while you were around and I said
yeah we didn't have social consciousness
we round the street cuz that's what a
[ __ ] was somebody said something by
Reno I said well the price is [ __ ]
right free love I feel like you were
like Rodney Dangerfield and back to
school I was down yeah lot of guys broke
my balls like that yeah yeah you
fighting for you did you go to like did
you go to the student parties and let go
to the I think these guys used to call
me up a tester I want to play Nintendo
the dead notice show me a four dollar
hooker that was in Vietnam and these
guys me playing beer pong you play a
beer pot go talk to the broads anyway
that's great
oh [ __ ] all you guys are listening to
the birds the effect episode 329 I'm
sitting here with corporate count Ryan
Sickler Billy O'Connor what it was such
a such a great time how we doing on time
here what do you got another another ten
oh yeah beautiful three four twelve got
eight dollars so we can all get laid
getting the ten back then must have been
like [ __ ] getting a 10-spot $10 must
have been nuts in Vietnam over there
yeah that was the commodity room we were
buying you know I mean they were feeding
if we were doing the right thing we were
spreading the little wealth around you
know I mean I was treated good I treat
no cos like Queens
that's one of my steals it was the Derek
Jeter gonna get it didn't get a Vietnam
gift bag here's four dollars for my
little Queen Oh like a queen and a queen
like a whole I can't [ __ ] this
[ __ ] miss Aristotle said right after
he was in Vietnam so you have imagine
you have a small check coming in is
payment from the government but the way
you're making your other money is just
by gambling and by I mean in Vietnam oh
it's all money were there yeah I always
make a lot of money playing poker that's
where you're making the real money I
make him more than you were getting paid
guys used to sit down in my poker game
with like you know put down there you
know to think you decide to take a card
you said what beats what you know and I
baby sitting there and I'm gonna want
the 20 game and I said a lot of this guy
he broke in 20 minutes I'm gonna rape
this prick you know like I was a hollom
gambler at that time already I was
already like I was into all that [ __ ]
poker but gamble so I was [ __ ] four
years old I actually played poker with
what I would uh [ __ ] was it little
Anthony the Imperials man blew Anthony
lippy riyals for the fifties II don't
remember that group oh no I can honestly
say finally I wasn't alive that's the
first time I've ever said that I've
never said that before I wasn't alive I
like this too said poker you played
played for money we played we played
yeah we played I was in I was outside
the city I was my dad grew up kind of
like where where you grew up we can't
without everything carried oh I don't
mean I became a book yeah I was so tired
of losing [ __ ] money well you said
something before that I think really
makes a lot of sense you said being a
stand-up for somebody that Gamble's it's
funny like Charles Barkley says the
reason he puts a hundred grand on games
is because he doesn't have that playing
in that rush he doesn't have in the
playoffs has to perform so he really
gambled a lot when he was done because
he got that feeling so what you're
saying is stand up you were going like
I'm going on stage right you were like
it's nervous you got to make them laugh
you might bomb you're scared and then
when you get done no matter
what happened something happened you get
that feeling examine and that's that's
guy still get it otherwise good when you
had 500 I remember when I had I remember
one time I was young I was in high
school and I didn't have money and I put
a hundred me and my friend would always
put a hundred on the on the home team on
Monday Night Football and we wanted a
lot Monday Night Football
home team covered a lot what you know I
remember we did the numbers look us do
it so we bet Green Bay creamy one and I
won like 300 $400 and then I want I got
greedy and it flipped to where I went
negative 700 I'm as a kid and I remember
being scared man like I didn't have it
and the guys like dude you know you
played with the big boys and [ __ ] like
you you owe $700 and I just remember
like when the pass is in the air a bomb
is in the air right and it's like a
[ __ ] 70 yard bomb to Maus when you've
got 200 hours on that [ __ ] like it makes
the it makes the whole difference is
such a [ __ ] unbelievable rush but you
can't win an NFL football can you you
can't go oh ok we're not gonna win Santa
jizz it's look it's mad you bet there's
a pure science they take a 10% right so
that means if say you put 10 games a
year 10 games a day 10 games period 6
out of 10 to break even
7 out of 10 them with a little bit of
money 8 out of 10 to win any real money
nobody can understand I give you a quick
story I had this guy degenerate gambler
Tony for red bag you don't know him the
Olympics I lose the bet with me years
ago he never met me I never met him but
even better but he was like six games
but nor Gamble's right yeah he never met
me but my voice I love that he tweety
tweety the money norm but anyway this
guy Tony for red degenerate gamble right
he calls me up [ __ ] Monday night for
MBA games in the toilet next night three
games NBA in a toilet next night two
nights south so it's like it's 40 losses
in a row in the NBA right calls me up on
a Monday night I give him his figure he
goes yeah yeah what do you got in the
NBA I guess is you know what man
Tony no NBA tonight all-star break yes I
got hockey [ __ ] do I know about hockey
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh my god dude this is so much
fun I could just listen about the pool
man have a lot of fun you guys are great
this looks great I gotta tell you man
Phoenix Phoenix is underrated for comedy
I was out here I was out here they gave
me a weekend here at stand-up live it
was amazing right before the special
people come out Tempe that Tempe room is
amazing
and people come out here people come out
like they wanna do this is a podcast
festival and people are [ __ ] in the
streets with badges and going to [ __ ]
yeah that'd be great it's great it's
really bad man it's it's a cool it's a
cool place to do it cuz some places
can't pull it off but it's cool you get
a lot of stage time in Phoenix you know
like if the kids coming out of college
the first thing he's thinking so I want
to go to New York don't want to go to LA
and you're gonna get lost above places
you know but nobody thinks let me go to
Phoenix but what a lot of headline is
coming from LA they need people to open
yeah so you know you get a lot of stage
time here I mean I got better you know
in the fight you bet anybody get better
because I'm a [ __ ] screwball yeah you
just did you were with Florentine right
at where a [ __ ] guy one of the one of
the gyms launches one of the nicest yes
days with you I appreciate [ __ ]
sweetheart I mean a really [ __ ] nice
guy he's Jim Jim is one of those guys
that you meet he's just like you're like
he's so [ __ ] cool man where'd you got
you what did you do which room did you
do House of comedy Rick Bronson okay
Rick is always good to me is it good
[ __ ] dirty red bump my books he keeps
one of the toilet I hope this doesn't
insult you but I keep your book in a
toilet I said no that's cool guys check
that out and buy and where could they
buy it where could they know what's
coming out it's called the mick it's
about a 911 I got hopes for that I got a
couple of what about the one that's on
confessions of a Bronx bookie and yeah
reviews are off the hook no you're a
great know this for the people that
don't know you know Billy's a really
great writer man writing good thing yeah
yeah it's that's well that's what you
went to school for and it's a really I
tell you
when I [ __ ] about that book in a year it
took me a year and a half to edit I
finally got so [ __ ] tired of looking
at that book I thumbtack one page each
page up to a wall and look to each
sentence true but I know I take out
[ __ ] extra is it's that's a burden
like I with my special my special is
finally gonna be done next week as far
as everything but I made sure in the
contract we negotiated that I had final
say yeah I had final editing say and as
much as that was great it was [ __ ] I
mean you're talking about all right Paul
version fives coming back you know Oscar
knows if Oscar
all right version six and I'm like yet
you know what that I don't want and then
here's the other thing then it with a
special you got a director and a
producer going you might want to keep
that and I'm like the desk now and then
and then but you also don't want to be
disrespectful because they've done it
and this is my first one so you know now
I'm talking what guy that's done it 20
30 times and I'm going no but so we meet
you meet and you're like okay and you
take but it's it's ready to you after a
while I'm like first we you know heart
is there's a comic to watch yourself do
to listen to yourself and to watch
yourself you're like look at me I'm a
[ __ ] I look like that and you're
looking at it under eyes that you're not
looking at it to enjoy it you're looking
at it yeah I get scared yeah I get
scared like I'm like yeah you have to
you have to watch it and I just like I
would watch 10 minutes and walk away cuz
it's really tough to do but finally it
got to the point where I just had to sit
down and go Paul this is this is it you
know so I can imagine a book no but good
for you man because let me tell you
something the rule of writing anything
is not cleaning up after the party
same thing with comedy I think it's not
cleaning up after the party anything is
the party writing is right first draft
of everything is [ __ ] how many ways said
that the first draft of everything is
[ __ ]
first rank you throw out it's just there
it doesn't get good you hold it that's
right yeah it's better sometimes it
grows you know it's like but it don't
start like that but I will tell any
comedian listening to this and everybody
is if you do do a project you have to
get as an artist you have to get to the
right you have to get the right and the
first contract that comes still never
the first contract that comes it's never
there it's never there the first one
like I'm like you they're always you
always got to be able to first want to
know everything they want first first
contracts everything they want yeah yeah
that's exact to you to go none of them
yeah the red line so do you guys do that
you strike no lawyers is worth as a
bookie it's worth five percent to have
somebody knows because they're doing
right look at your [ __ ] yeah it took me
a long time to sign on the dotted line
I'll take the four dollars yeah no you
got to be protective you got it you got
to be protected cuz like Ryan just said
the first one is so skewed and not your
in your favor
not your favor that you're like listen
and they know that's the funniest part
there's not even a real contract a lot
of times it's just some proposal just
some [ __ ] we want then you beat it up
but yeah like if you sign it they'd be
[Music]
$4 son of a [ __ ] yeah one thing I do on
the show it's a part of my show is
unacceptable for the week that is kind
of my you know Letterman top ten list so
to speak so I know you guys I didn't
prepare you guys for that and I usually
do one the listeners guys I do have one
for you and this was I've never had this
happen to me before I got picked up
early in the morning to come out to
Phoenix the cab driver was there and I
noticed I don't he had a small head you
know and and I don't know I don't know
if that has something to do with it but
like I just noticed like it was almost
small to the point where I was like is
this it like like that what's that virus
to [ __ ] that the physique of what yeah
makes your head small there's a virus
what's a quick Beetlejuice like little
Beetlejuice a Zika the Zika virus is
something that makes you yeah it was
your [ __ ] head yeah yeah but I don't
know what he was I mean it wasn't it
wasn't like that but it wasn't it wasn't
it was something dude I get in the car
and and I'm telling you every stop I was
I was actually almost somebody said
please live Facebook what you're doing
cuz I was on Facebook going this [ __ ]
guy is stopping every time he stopped
was as if he was gonna hit a wall every
time and I'm going like this and I'm
starting to mutter myself this [ __ ] I'm
getting sick I'm gay and I just threw up
snorkeling in Hawaii so the same [ __ ]
starts to happen and I'm going I'm not
gonna forget my throwing up on the way
to this festival I can't I mean [ __ ]
exhausted and he's
stopping and he's gone and I'm going huh
and I'm going this [ __ ] then he missed
the terminal so as he was missing the
terminal it was more Billy I was [ __ ] I
knew thought I was on a cruise ship and
I almost jumped out of the [ __ ] cab
that's how much I wanted to get out of
the cab it was one of the most and and
it was [ __ ] horrible then I get on
the plane and as people are boarding the
plane when's the captain get on during
that as you're stepping on the captain
not you know when you when you step on
you see the flight attendant go hey and
you go to your [ __ ] flight it I mean
the captain gets on I'm nauseous now I
did tell what that I could barely eat
breakfast
the lady was like are you alright she's
a club soda like I was like that at the
airport cuz cuz of a cab right there
unacceptable then then the [ __ ]
capitana captain goes hey folks a
captain here in a cockpit and I'm going
this never happens he goes look we're
not gonna be serving anything for the
first 35 of the flight we're gonna be in
some really rough turbulence until we
get past Pittsburgh I swear to God then
we're gonna be in to really rough
turbulence until we pass Pittsburgh but
you know give it about 30 35 minutes and
he didn't lie he didn't [ __ ] lie that
plane was getting to the point with
people like you know the guy Joe
matarese has a bit about the guy who
plays it cool reading even during it
that guy was like doing work and it got
to the point where that guy just put his
head back like the guy it went from like
the guy who was a [ __ ] professional
flyer like I don't care to where he just
went you know he laid back and he put
his head back like let's get through
this and it was just that it was just
but that cab drop that cab ride was one
of now my wife's I'm gonna ask you guys
a question might because my wife said we
that cab ride cost me from my house to
the airport cost me 175 damn okay yeah
cuz I live I live one hour north of
Manhattan but I had to go to Newark and
it was 7:00 in the morning and I was out
I was I did a show the night before so I
just I didn't want to drive so I I'm my
wife I'm gonna stay stay I'm getting
sick this guy can't drive he was
stopping even like 15 yards before a car
hard like I was almost to the point guys
he was I thought he was [ __ ] with me
that's how bad it was my wife says since
it cost me that much I should call the
company but then my question is I don't
want that guy knowing where the [ __ ] I
live I don't want to be do you know what
I mean like he picked me up so what do
you think should I just cuz it's
expensive should I try to but I don't
I'm not never get you're never getting
that money back yeah
yeah possible small hill centerra you
know it'd be funny if I called up next
time and I'm like Billie thank you for
saying that's the other thing I forgot I
left out this guy's a [ __ ] true steel
trap this guy we're in the right [ __ ]
lane we're in the right lane and people
are kind of flowing left and he goes is
the is the left one faster did you drive
for a [ __ ] that's like a comic being
like should I hit the punch line I think
some guy with the Zika virus took his
brother's cab that morning and decided
to give you a ride to the airport and he
had heavier shoes on and I couldn't
believe it so it was it was really let's
talk about this for a second guys have
fetishes I don't understand this one
this is the one I don't understand
there's a couple ones I don't understand
jerking off on a girl's foot i I guess I
guess I am sorry I've just just took a
weird turn but normal
what about well what about the guys that
just want the girl's clothes on and they
just into some like some stuff that's
not sexual like you know like to just
ask Billy for dollars over yeah what I
used to ask cookies and I dressed
everybody all the time I always say you
know cuz we're [ __ ] comics we're
curious we're [ __ ] writers curious I
say what's the weirdest [ __ ] thing
anybody goes
yeah how does he find this out he was
working a State Fair feel better than
this is a big [ __ ] great orange
girlfriend Cindy we're doing it again
Tropicana guys here I know it's out
there but I'd step in on that I was a
five and I checked used to come in I was
working in the village one day a chief
or drop off the checks once a week now
payday we'd have a couple of beers in
the face when 11 beers wait can we cash
the checks the only place is open the
village was a place called Alex everyone
the lands right skate Club in a village
right yeah we get six five overall drunk
buy a round of drinks you got a fire out
of tricks you get the checks cashed this
guy goes to the bathroom because but I
say it is a guy lighter than your
[Laughter]
I made some good money that week at the
village we were in I was in South
Carolina with my buddy I was performing
in Myrtle Beach and I was like dude
let's make a prank phone call he's I say
you know what be a funny thing I go
let's call an escort and and and come up
with something weird
so my friends listening to me and I call
up and I just changed my voice and I was
like hey man yeah I was like I'm having
a rough week can you get a can you get a
girl over here I was like the thing is I
have a little weird I have a weird
request and I'm kind of thinking us on
the fly and she goes well what what's
what's your regret request and I was
like I'm really into baseball so I was
like number and and pumps I was like she
has to be in red or pink pumps and he's
like we could make that happen we have a
lot of shoes here I was like good as I
go I'm really into baseball so I need
her to sing the national anthem in the
living room okay full-fledged she does
she tell the words and everything he
goes hold on this [ __ ] went back
started and it was probably like a
lifelong dream oh my god it was like it
was like a lifelong dream to do it at a
game so this is their one chance so he
comes back and he's like all right we
could we could do that and I was like
and everything has to be in like
baseball's terms like everything and we
[ __ ] and we started to get it going my
friends crying and then I [ __ ] the
call up cuz we were just laughing so
hard but when he said hold on and he
said we could make that work he actually
took a minute and probably the girls
girls I got a weird one and just one
girl was like [ __ ] I'll do it South
Carolina true story second chapter my
book I swear to God I call a hooker
never been in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina in my life that chick shows up
but I know her
yeah I [ __ ] know but my name is Fred
yeah holiday and though she comes in she
goes oh come on I said shame what the
[ __ ] are you doing in so Selim is what
are you doing I think it's a buying it
right Michael Pachter Dion this is true
is God can I tell blinky my book my cap
on Isis blinky what the [ __ ] I'm a sat
down on a choice I'd never been here
before my life I call a [ __ ] hooker
and I know I said what's the [ __ ]
odds Jesus would you
oh my god yo this [ __ ] I've cried like
this on a show this is great man's
diversity effect podcast guys episode
329 having such a great time here at
Court McCown Ryan Sickler Billy O'Connor
I've been crying on my show I haven't
cried like this
you guys got plugs man what do you guys
got coming up you guys got to check
these guys out go to their shows and
follow them they're all great dudes
great people first and that's why
they're on the show but they're also so
[ __ ] funny you guys are talking to
some of the funny everybody here at this
festival to talk about some of the
funniest people in the world so follow
them what do you got Cort McGowan go to
court McGowan spent last name MC Co W in
court McGowan check court out Ron what
do you got Ryan Sickler calm on all
social media Ryan Sickler and check out
my podcast the crab feast what you're
gonna be doing tonight yes I'll be on
the crab feast tonight
sensitivity training with your buddy Joe
Barton yes and I just did in sensitivity
training with those guys yesterday and
Billy what you got Billy O'Connor go to
a Bronx Billy calm and I check out my
new book the mick it's gonna be out in
November confessions for Bronx boogie I
got a couple sold-out comedy shows in
New York to push the books I think the
fire department's gonna be there give me
sirens and all the [ __ ] that's great
we'll see what guys come out tonight to
stand up live I'll be there on The Late
Show also a tomorrow night I will be
with the very funny Joe Bartnik I will
be doing laughing up in Poughkeepsie
I also got Cabot coming I got a bunch of
new dates that just hit the website so
you could check that out Paul virzi comm
follow me on Twitter at Paul virzi you
guys are the best until episode 3:30 we
are out of here thank you take care
thanks guys
[Applause]